- C'est parti!
Après les controverses,
polémiques et appels at,t,t,t,t,
la grande fête du football
est officiellement lancée
et les Canadiens y participent
cette fois-ci.
Les violations des droits de
la personne au Qatar suscitent
de nombreux appels au boycott
de ce tournoi.
Près de 7 000 travailleurs
étrangers seraient morts
sur les chantiers de
la Coupe du monde au Qatar
ces dernières années
dans des conditions
s'apparentant à de
l'esclavagisme.
Certaines sélections,
dont celle des Pays-Bas,
ont tenu à rencontrer
des travailleurs migrants.
Le Qatar réprime les
Le Qatar réprime lesdrdrdrdrdr.
Les partisans étrangers
devraient être tolérés
par les organisateurs,
mais les Qataris pourraient
être victimes d'encore plus de
répression après le tournoi.
Le bilan environnemental
du tournoi organisé dans le
désert fait aussi polémique,
tout comme les conditions
Le bilan environnemental
du tournoi organisé dans le
désert fait aussi polémique,
tout comme les conditions
d'hébergement et
les restrictions sur la
consommation d'alcool.
Exaspérée, la FIFA condamne
les critiques et accuse
le monde occidenta
d'hypocrisie sur la question
des droits de la personne.
Pour le Canada
et ses partisans,
ce tournoi est historique.gigige
participation à la Coupe
du monde, la première fois
depuis 1986.
- Et puis, cette équipe,elle va.
On va affronter la Belgique,
la Croatie, mais ne vous
inquiétez pas. Ça sera
une surprise que le Canada
va créer dans ce mondial!
- Scène encourageante
pour l'équipe canadienne,
trois joueurs-clé blessés,
dont la vedette Alphonso Davies,
ont participé à l'entraînement.
Pour les par,,,,,,,,,
tous les espoirs sont permis.
Ici Philippe Leblanc,
Radio-Canada, Doh